the the debate this month it reads in
terms of its resolution free market
ideology is largely responsible for the
Dismal performance of the U.S economy
over the past few decades please vote
yes no or undecided on the resolution in
order for us to determine who gets the
soul Forum tootsie roll and because I am
speaking for the negative on this debate
resolution I've got to recuse myself for
the rest of the evening from moderating
and I bring you for the rest of the
evening
Nick Gillespie editor at large of Reason
Nick please come on stage
hi everybody I am Nick Gillespie I'm
with Friesen I want to thank you all for
coming out it's a great night and it's
going to be a great night of debate
um there is I want to also thank the
Donald Smith Family Foundation for uh
helping to fund these debates as well as
reason the company that I work for there
are free issues of Reason out in the
crowd please take them read them share
them put them on the front seats and the
toilets of people that you dislike so
that maybe they will learn something new
and different and wonderful tonight's uh
resolution of course is free market
ideology is largely responsible for the
Dismal performance of the U.S economy
over the past few decades and Binya
Applebaum of the New York Times is the
main uh debater against Gene Epstein
Binya could you take the stage please
um
[Applause]
binyu will be uh defending the
proposition Gene will be uh taking the
negative and the way it's going to work
is that Vineyard will go for 20 minutes
Gene will go for 20. we'll have five
minutes of rebuttal 30 minutes of
questions from uh the audience both here
and online uh live streaming thank you
so much for joining us via the Internet
and then five minute uh finishing
statements and and then we'll vote and
then we'll go and party at Gene and
osakos which is perhaps the real reason
Gene never had parties as a child he
doesn't like to talk about it but maybe
that's what we're doing here so um let's
get started uh Benya could you please uh
take this take the podium and make your
openings oh I'm sorry Jane please close
the voting
and now vinya please take the stage
good evening
there's a joke I like uh about two men
who are standing uh at a parade at a
military parade and they're watching as
tanks go by and soldiers go by and
missile trucks go by and finally the
last truck in the parade goes past
carrying a couple of you know guys in
jackets and glasses and the first guy
says to his friend who's that and the
second guy says oh those are the
economists you won't believe all the
damage they can do
well my burden tonight is to convince
you that there's some truth in that joke
uh and and I think that's going to have
to take two parts the first is to
convince you that there is a problem
which may not be intuitive to all of you
and the second part is is to convince
you that my explanation of the problem
is correct so let's start with the
nature of the problem the idea that the
United States economy has in some
important sense
I performed dismally
that obviously runs up against the fact
that the United States economy has grown
and in fact has grown more quickly than
the economies of other developed Nations
for the most part in recent decades and
really what uh I and I didn't choose the
word but I think you know what I mean
when I say that the United States has
had problems economically is that our
economy has not performed as well as it
could have or should have and in
particular that the distribution of our
prosperity has been uneven which is both
a problem in and of itself and one
reason that growth has been
disappointing in recent decades for me
the statistic that really embodies
what has gone wrong economically for the
United States is a comparison between
the United States and France I think a
lot of Americans feel some satisfaction
uh in in a sense that we grow faster
than France We compare ourselves to them
and think that we're doing better and in
the aggregate we are the American
economy has undoubtedly grown faster
than France if you look at the period
between 1975 and 2006 average household
incomes in the United States increased
by 32.2 percent and in France by just
27.1 percent comparisons with other
developed economies are similar the
United States has on average produced
more economic growth what happens though
if you strip out the top one percent of
American households and the top one
percent of French households is that the
numbers look very different in America
the average uh growth in household
incomes for 99 of the population is 17.9
percent over that period while in France
it's 26.4 percent you may notice that
the French numbers remain very similar
not much of the economic growth in
France has been concentrated in the
hands of that Elite whereas here in the
United States a very large share of the
economic growth has been concentrated in
the hands of the elite and by that
measure which to me is more important
than aggregate GDP growth because
ultimately an economy is a collection of
people and what we care about is the
welfare of all those people by that
measure we are underperforming other
countries we're not doing particularly
well frankly we're growing quite slowly
if by we you mean most of us and not
just those one percent of the population
who happen to live disproportionately in
this neighbor Broad and perhaps some of
you are in the audience tonight
second Point life expectancy to me there
is no greater measure of the failure of
the American economy than the fact that
Americans are dying at younger ages than
they used to this is shocking and before
the covet pandemic unprecedented in
developed societies there has been a
straightforward March upward in terms of
life expectancy with very limited
exceptions for example during World War
II but during periods of Peace time it
has been a stable and reliable fact that
with each passing year people will tend
to live longer and that was true in the
United States until about five years ago
when life expectancy finally tipped over
and began to decline the driver of this
is very straightforward there's once
again a huge disjoint between the
quality of life at the top of the
economic spectrum and at the bottom a
man in the top fifth of the economic
spectrum will live on average in America
13 years longer than a man in the bottom
fifth of the economic distribution and
that divide has doubled since 1980. that
to me is a shocking statistic it really
speaks to the ways in which our economy
is failing a significant portion of our
population
there's a final measure by which I think
we have a big economic problem and
that's opportunity it's easy enough to
say that people's lives end up in
different places we know that has to do
with them as much as with their societal
surroundings or contexts some people
succeed others fail some people deserve
to do better others do not put in the
work or have the ideas or have the luck
but in the United States our problem is
increasingly that how your life ends up
is determined by how it begins when my
father was born in the early 1950s
roughly 75 percent of American men of
his generation ended up earning more
than their parents had in their middle
income years that the prime earning
years of their adulthood
for my cohort of adults that number is
less than half the evidence that we have
suggests that it has declined further
since then what we're seeing is that
people are struggling to keep Pace with
the lives that their parents had they're
struggling to pursue opportunity and one
particularly striking pattern is that
where they are born determines their
Destiny So within a single urban area
there are increasingly large divides
between the prospects for children born
in the poorest neighborhoods and the
prospects for children born in the
richest neighborhoods people's Fates are
determined not by their efforts not by
their aptitude but by the accident of
birth by where they happen to be born by
the opportunities afforded to them in
that neighborhood in that context the
levels of pollution the quality of
Education the access to role models to
jobs all of these things Factor
increasingly heavily into the American
experience and so our self-image of
ourselves as a nation in which people
can succeed and chase a dream and grow
and and find riches it is now the case
that that is more true of Europe than it
is of the United States we have fallen
behind in terms of social Mobility we
have stopped being the place where a
young woman or a young man has the best
chance to chase those dreams so that is
to me the problem that working fronting
and then we come to the diagnosis the
question of why that's happening and
whether in any sense free market
ideology can be blamed
[Music]
my my story really begins
in the late 1960s in the early 1970s
when there was a market shift in the way
that our government approached problems
uh and and handled the basic task of
governing a shift in ideology that was
driven by the economists
who uh you know the in that military
parade seemed to pose such a great
threat those guys had an idea about how
an economy ought to work they thought
that markets should play a larger role
in the distribution of resources uh in
in answering questions about how a
society should approach its challenges
and they began to exercise a persuasive
influence over the federal government
first year in the United States later in
other countries as well one of the
earliest chapters in that story is
actually military conscription which if
it's not a story you're familiar with
may come as a surprise to you
up until the early 1970s military
conscription in this country was in
essence Universal not everybody was
actually enroll old in the armed forces
but everyone was eligible unless they
had some specific exemption and that was
the way that we and most other developed
Nations filled the ranks of our Armed
Forces well economists began to argue
and with considerable Logic on their
side that this was not an efficient way
of finding soldiers it didn't make any
sense to have Sergeant Elvis Presley in
the ranks he would be better off singing
he didn't want to send Willie Mays
overseas to fight you wanted him to stay
home and entertain people by hitting
home runs it was very inefficient to
take the people who might be teachers or
doctors or what have you and send them
to be soldiers what you should do is you
should find the people who wanted to be
soldiers or pay people enough to
convince them to be soldiers and you'd
end up with a better military people
would remain engaged in the military for
longer they would do a better job they
would be better soldiers and Society
would then have the benefit of realizing
the potential of the people who didn't
want to be soldiers this was a very
powerful idea and it was ultimately
persuasive to Richard Nixon who moved to
end the draft one of the ironies of the
end of the draft is it did not end
because of the opponents of the Vietnam
War at the end of the draft was not
primarily driven by the people who hated
the use of conscripted soldiers in
Vietnam it was driven by the proponents
of the Vietnam War who thought that by
changing the terms of military service
they could temper some of those protests
and preserve the ability of the American
Military to be used in in foreign
engagements and so Nixon acted on the
advice of these economists who he had
assembled in a presidential advisory
commission which at the time were all
the rage and he got rid of the draft on
the advice of those economists including
Milton Friedman a name many of you may
be familiar with who was probably the
most influential member of that
commission that idea in its application
to the draft may seem like a really good
idea to many people I think it probably
was but that same principle that markets
should be used to allocate resources was
increasingly applied in other areas of
government policy with increasingly
harmful consequences and so what you see
over the following decades is that the
government begins to approach all of its
nails with this Hammer to take the same
set of solutions and apply them to all
manner of problems and that's that's
where things really start to go wrong
and I want to go through just a couple
of areas as examples of that to give you
a sense of the broader Story one which I
suspect everyone here lived through
although the years march on is the
financial crisis that we experienced in
the late you know 2000 and date and
forward which was caused in large
measure by the deregulation of financial
markets by the freedom of financial
firms to experiment and to sell products
to customers that their customers
neither understood nor could safely own
with devastating consequences for the
American economy this was a
straightforward application of free
market ideology to our economy and the
consequences were not wonderful there
are more interesting examples though one
of my favorites
is the work of a man named George
Stigler who was probably Milton
Friedman's closest friend they made a
very odd pair Friedman was very short
and talkative Stigler very tall and thin
and quiet and they'd go strolling around
the Chicago campus together and that
image endured in the minds of many of
their disciples they were a pair and
intellectually as well Stigler wrote a
very famous paper in which he argued
that the government did not need to
regulate cartels
organizations of businesses for the
purpose of restraining for the purpose
of raising prices and restraining
production because
cartels would fall apart naturally they
were unsustainable in a market economy
there was such a huge incentive for
businesses to cheat that someone always
would and therefore the government could
just stand by and let cartels Blossom
and fall apart and and the economy would
essentially be unaffected this
prescription
became Dogma in Washington the federal
government embraced it and stopped
hunting for cartels for 7 several
decades until in the mid-1990s someone
had the clever idea to create a reward
program at the Department of Justice
where the first company to report its
participation in a cartel would get a
get out of jail free card and the other
companies in the cartel would be held
accountable all you had to do was to get
to the doj office first this was
approved as an experimental program
nobody knew what to expect indeed the
guy who created it who was an economist
didn't think it was going to attract
many takers because he understood that
there were not very many cartels in the
economy that was you know the thing that
he expected but what happened almost
immediately is that companies started
rushing to the justice department to
report that they were participants in
cartels the program was overwhelmed they
had to assign more staff to it because
it turned out that actually George
Stigler was completely wrong and that
cartels were remarkably common in
American Business and unfortunately
remained surprisingly common right up
until the present day I was just reading
a story about real estate companies
getting together to set prices for
apartments using algorithms to determine
the prices that they would all
collectively charge so this type of
business Behavior remains remarkably
persistent and needs to be regulated it
doesn't go away on its own cartels do
not fall apart just because the market
economy says so
my own paper the New York Times ran an
editorial in 1986 calling for the
abolition of the minimum wage on the
grounds that it was you know not logical
as a free market principle that it was
you know a Restraint of trade basically
that it was a distortion of the market
economy
uh we've learned since that that was not
a great idea the evidence suggests that
labor markets actually are inefficient
and that you can set a minimum wage not
any minimum wage but you can set a
minimum wage without reducing the number
of people who are employed uh in a given
area it turned out when you went and
looked at the evidence at the ground
level uh what we thought was true from
economic theory and what had reshaped
economic policy for a generation was in
fact not the right set of conclusions to
draw I can go on with examples probably
one of the most important is that our
failure to regulate externalities is
currently causing the planet to overheat
but the bottom line is that markets
don't work by themselves and if you
allow them too much freedom to roam what
you get is outcomes that are bad for the
market and bad for the people who live
in that market economy and that's really
the point that I want to make you know
as I move to the conclusion here is that
markets and Society markets and and the
government exist in a form of productive
tension too much Market too much
government and you get bad results what
you need ultimately is balance what you
need is that Dynamic back and forth
tension between the two where you're
constantly trying to find the right
point between them and not let things
slip too far to one side or too far to
the other during the coronavirus
pandemic we all learned the importance
of government investment in basic
research in government support for the
development of vaccines in government
coordination of the distribution of
medical supplies we learned that if you
allow some things to be produced solely
in China you can end up in a strangely
vulnerable position when you need those
things those are all functions of
government that had been allowed to
wither and that had been allowed to Fall
by the wayside and in the absence of
which people suffered and quite
literally died for an absence of
government in their lives
um democracy ultimately needs to hold
markets accountable and make them work
the purpose of a government is to
structure the marketplace in ways that
deliver the outcomes that people want
and need and what people need in their
lives is a degree of Economic Security
and a degree of access to opportunity
one very interesting finding from the
work of an economist named Pietro Rivoli
is that the level of anti-trade
sentiment in the United States
opposition to globalization is much
higher or was over the last couple
decades much higher than in nations with
stronger social safety nets and her
theory is that in Nations that afforded
their citizens Access to Health Care on
a guaranteed basis that provided
stronger minimum wages stronger
retraining programs that basically said
listen you can fall thus far but no
further we're going to make sure that
life does not get any worse than a
certain minimum level that in those
Nations the stakes seemed lower to the
workers and they were more willing to
accept the types of change changes that
a market economy can ultimately use to
produce Dynamic and beneficial results
they were willing to get behind trade
what happened here in the United States
is I think an instructive tale for
proponents of the market economy the
thing that they wanted the thing that
they believed in the thing that they
regarded as an engine of prosperity and
I may say so do I I think the trade is
really important but it's not
sustainable as a political proposition
if you are not tempering it with
programs that meet the needs of your
citizens and ensure that those who are
the short-term losers in the inevitable
redistributions caused by free trade are
getting what they need from society as a
whole are recompensed for their losses
so that the proposition that trade can
be beneficial to everyone which is
undoubtedly true becomes the reality the
trade is beneficial to everyone rather
than the more common reality in which
some people lose because that
redistribution never happens we are
living with the political consequences
of that experiment and the lesson for
people who constantly emphasize the
beauty of them Market is that the market
is beautiful but it's not sustainable if
it's not potted in a garden in which
people can get what they need and do not
need to fear the consequences for
themselves there's a famous quote from
The Economist Frank Knight that markets
must sometimes be seasoned with Mercy
the point is that you'll never get there
with your formulas there's always going
to be a rationale for ignoring that side
of things but you ignore it at your own
Peril if you treat markets as the BL and
dendall is the absolute engine of
prosperity you will miss the
consequences that will ultimately make
it impossible to persist with a market
economy and I fear that that's very much
where we are right now our faith in
markets is threatening our ability to
have markets working for us and to
deliver Prosperity
inequality is jeopardizing liberal
democracy in the United States it's
making it harder for we the people to
have enough in common to govern
ourselves effectively or to agree on an
economic agenda it's jeopardizing that
sort of foundation of common interest
that is necessary for democracy to
function and ultimately necessary for a
market to function because the market is
ultimately happening in the context of
society and if Society breaks down so
does that market mechanism
uh
markets are characterized by the ability
to walk away I think of that as
ultimately the defining characteristic
of a market you don't have to do the
deal you don't have to make the purchase
you don't have to make the sale markets
are about choice but if a society
persists in making the choice to walk
away as America has tended to do it
persists in making the choice to go
build something else to start over to
ignore the hard questions of how we make
the markets that we have sustainable you
get to a very bad place and I fear
that's where we're headed
foreign
thank you uh very much uh Gene Epstein
20 minutes
just make sure this is working
yeah
so please start my time now okay
uh
I believe that the economy's
disappointing performance over the past
few decades is largely due to
Progressive ideology but I'm relieved
that I don't have to convince you of my
view in the brief time allotted since
it's a vast topic Benya has graciously
taken on the burden of proving his view
that free market ideology is largely to
blame
I hope you don't come away thinking that
the free market properly defined Bears
even partial responsibility but even if
you do you'll still vote against the
more ambitious resolution Binya is
defending
let me begin with a couple of trends
that should put the employability of
binya's case in perspective Progressive
ideologues generally believe government
spending is too low and government
regulation too limited and they
generally seek an increase in both
free market idea logs believe the
opposite and seek a decrease in both
Binya believes free market ideologues
have had undue influence but in these
two major areas progressives have gotten
their way on both counts
take government spending
as this chart shows total government
spending on the federal state and local
level has had already risen to 30.5
percent of nominal gross domestic
product by 1969 and government spending
has accounted for a higher percentage of
nominal GDP in every year since then
notice we hit an all-time record of 43.7
percent in 2020 and fell back to 40.9
percent in 2021 the second highest
figure and the most recent year
available
now consider government regulation
as this chart shows there were 180 000
pages in the code of federal regulations
by 2019 the most recent year available a
tripling since 1969's 58
000 Pages that's pretty compelling
evidence that the burden of Regulation
has greatly increased
now let's shift arvo Focus to widening
income inequality the evidence is clear
and compelling that much of the greater
inequality in the veil vital area of
Labor compensation can be traced not to
the free market but to the increased
role of government in thwarting the
mobility of Labor in the free market
starting with government's imposition of
restrictive licensing requirements that
make it costly in terms of time and
money for workers to switch to higher
paying jobs the percentage of workers
subject to such requirements has jumped
from 10 percent in 1970 to nearly 30
percent today and two-thirds of the
increase has spread to more occupation
virtually all of them covering jobs that
the less educated could take Studies
have shown that these requirements do
virtually nothing to improve the quality
of service in these jobs but is simply
the same old use of government power to
keep out competition in his 1962 book
capitalism and freedom free market
Economist Milton Friedman had already
called for a rollback of restrictive
licensing requirements then in place and
instead of a rollback we have seen a
massive government government imposed
increase that shafts many of the most
vulnerable
then there's the other far more
destructive way in which government has
been impeding the mobility of workers
this is the accelerated rise since the
1960s and government imposed rules regs
and restrictions that make it
increasingly expensive to build housing
in high-wage areas like New York and San
Francisco the resulting scarcity of
supply has driven up the price of
housing in these areas making it
increasingly costly for low-wage workers
to move to these areas and to take
advantage of the higher wages
here is how one account summarizes the
problem quote
High income workers still enjoy a net
wage premium when they move to a high
wage area and thus still have an
incentive to move but for Less skilled
workers the regulatory tax on housing
wipes out any wage premium as a result
College grads continue to move to human
capital hubs while less educated workers
who would stand to gain the most by
moving are kept Away by artificial
scarcity unquote with college grads
benefiting and less educated workers
shut out we have a perfect recipe for
the widening gap between the earnings of
the two groups a 2019 peer-reviewed
study by two economists quote quantifies
spatial misallocation of Labor across
U.S cities and its aggregate costs
unquote as the economists explained
quote misallocation arises because High
productivity cities like New York and
San Francisco have adopted stringent
restrictions to new housing Supply
effectively limiting the number of
workers who have access to such high
productivity unquote they put the cost
to workers at an absolute minimum at a
staggering nine percent of gross
domestic product
a New York Times column of February 24th
helps sound the alarm on the issue in
the New York area the author calls for
quote a change of the rules so that
quote developers could begin to build
more of the housing that New York so
desperately needs without spending
decades begging for permission unquote
note how the columnist stands up for the
developers the very capitalists that
progressives have been taught to despise
the columnist forthrightly points out
that these capitalists can build housing
that is quote desperately needed if only
government would back off
well that admirable column was written
by none other than my debate opponent
Benya Applebaum
but if Pena can argue for unshackling
the free market in housing that
logically requires him to abandon his
argument that it's largely to blame in
the area of widening income inequality
much of benya's argument about the
supposed connection between bad outcomes
and the free market is based on
conjecture but he does make one attempt
to demonstrate that his argument is not
merely conjectural which I want to take
seriously his very specific Claim about
the pattern of slowed economic growth
over the period he covers his argument
is that free market ideology began to
dominate by the late 1960s to the 1970s
and that as a result economic growth
slowed in each of the Decades that
followed I'll show how his factual claim
does not quite withstand scrutiny in a
podcast interview benion made do
allowance for the difficulty of
explaining why economic growth slows
quote our understanding of growth he
stated is highly incomplete and we are
to some extent talking about things we
don't fully understand unquote but
despite conceding a limited grasp of the
factors that cause economic growth to
slow he still claims to find a trend
that lights up the road
quote but it is a fact he goes on to say
that average growth declined in every
decade from the 1960s through the Arts
in the United States adjusted for
population and it is a fact that during
that period we saw a fundamental shift
in our approach to managing the economy
unquote
the fundamental shift he refers to is of
course the alleged ever tightening grip
of free market ideology he continues
quote if we think that that approach
promoting free market ideology was
consequential it's not unreasonable at
least to wonder about how it might have
affected that Trend unquote to emphasize
the importancy places on that Trend let
me also quote this from his book quote
the market Revolution went too far
growth slowed in each successive decade
during the half century described in
this book adjusting for population and
inflation unquote notice he emphasizes
that each successive decade suffered a
Slowdown from the previous decade by
adjusting for inflation he means real or
inflation-adjusted growth in gross
domestic products and by adjusting for
population he means growth of real GDP
per capita as mentioned and the best
evidence is that Progressive ideology
not free market ideology has become
increasingly dominant but Pena is also
mistaken about the pattern of slowed
growth which leaves a major flaw in his
core argument here are the numbers
provided in this book on growth of real
GDP per capita which span 10-year
periods and which report to show a
Slowdown in each successive decade with
each of his 10-year periods ending in
the ninth year of each decade let's
start reading those numbers from top to
bottom it's clear that growth slowed
from the 60s to the 70s from 3.13
percent to 2.160 percent
now look at the next step growth slowed
from the 70s to the 80s from 2.160
percent to
2.156 percent
but was this really slowed growth 2.160
to 2.156 Binya had to take these numbers
to three decimal places to get his
desired decline round each of these
figures to two decimal places and you
get 2.16 in each case which comes to a
flat Trend this inspires the old joke
that if you torture numbers long enough
they'll confess to anything and Pena's
been used three decimal point torture
clearly indicates how much the pattern
matters to him even the next step from
the 80s to the 90s from 2.156 percent to
1.98 percent looks a little suspect a
Slowdown of less than two tenths of a
percentage point
I put each of these annual numbers on a
spreadsheet grouped them enrolling
10-year periods and found the pattern is
sensitive to which years you choose
while there is a Slowdown from the 60s
to the 70s and from the 90s to the odds
the middle decades show no real pattern
but a relatively flat trend
as one way of illustrating this I'll
show how easy it is to get the reverse
patterns from Vineyards in the middle
decades by tracking 10-year periods that
differ by only two years from his since
the updated numbers go through 2021 the
most recent year available I worked
backwards from there so each of my
tenure peers ends in the first year of
the following decade I got this as a
result also taken to three decimal
places to stay consistent with benya's
method let's also read these numbers
from top to bottom we see a similar
decline from the 60s to the 70s from
3.070 percent to 2.040 percent but from
the 70s to the 1990s we get a slight
acceleration instead of being used
slight deceleration
2.040 percent in the 70s
2.046 in the 80s and 2.329 in the 90s
the 90s to the Arts show a similar
slowdown from 2.356 percent to
0.926 the odds to the teens do show a
pickup but the 1.488 rate in the teens
is still pretty dismal
the point is that the middle decades
deprived Binya of the linchpin of his
argument that growth slowed in each
successive decade over the period under
review he wants us to believe that the
grip of free market ideology placed a
gradual choke hold on growth now we are
forced to believe the alleged impact was
felt only twice somewhat prematurely
from the 60s to the 1970s since by
benue's own account free market ideology
was beginning to wield only beginning to
wield destructive influence in the 70s
we then find zero impact in causing a
Slowdown in growth from the 1970s to
1980s which included the presidency of
free market ideologue Ronald Reagan and
zero impact from the 80s to the 90s
instead we had to wait nearly 30 years
until the Yachts for the impact to be
felt a second time
the corrected Trend must send Binya back
to the drawing board to devise some
other attempt at a coherent narrative
given the relative incoherence of his
current narrative his initial disclaimer
still applies quote our understanding of
growth is highly incomplete and we are
to some extent talking about things we
don't fully understand unquote
I could elaborate on a totally different
explanation for the slowdown in growth
since 2000 that I regard as more
plausible having to do with the decline
in the economic freedom index since 2000
which reveals the declining influence of
the free market but I want to use the
time remaining to make two more General
points
I'm about to quote from a passage in
venue's book that betrays a certain
mindset about the free market he writes
the following about the state of poverty
in the early 1960s quote
about a fifth of the American population
then lived in destitution with little
Prospect of betterment both liberal and
conservative administrations had taken
the view that poverty was best treated
by pursuing broad economic growth but by
the early 1960s Scholars and journalists
were focusing public attention on the
inadequacy of this strategy unquote
so if it's been your rights there was
quote little prospective betterment
among those in poverty we can only
assume that things hadn't been getting
better for quite a while and if the
scholars involved were focusing on
public attention on the inadequacy of
the strategy we must assume this was
based on their scholarly research and we
further assume this scholarly research
lent support to the federal government's
announcement of its war on poverty in
1964. Benya cites no data in this
account but now try a very different
narrative that does cite relevant data
from social scientist Charles Murray
quote in 1949 41 percent of Americans
were below the poverty line when LBJ
announced the war in poverty in 1964
that proportion had dropped to 19
percent in just the 15 years between
1949 and 1964 the American poverty rate
had dropped by 22 percentage points what
had the government done to help by the
definition of the 1960s and thereafter
nothing the federal government was
missing in action in the real war
against poverty and yet somehow America
cut poverty by more than half over this
period Well the trend Murray cites as
was well known when Bina wrote his
mistaken account I suggest that this
reveals a certain bias despite binya's
occasional nods to the benefits of the
free market in areas that include such
Trends as the decline in poverty the
decline in the rate of auto accidents
and the increase decrease in injuries in
the workplace the progressive assumption
is that government regulation is
required to fix the problem since the
free market has done virtually nothing
to fix it these misdependent part on
ignoring the evidence the trends like
these were noticeably improving before
government got involved it's a short
step from there when considering any bad
outcome to regard the free market as
guilty until proven innocent and
government innocent until proven guilty
finally I can't avoid mentioning
mentioning something else in benue's
book that falls into major error he
places great significance on the trend
displayed in this charge the long-term
downtrend in all wages and salaries as a
percentage of gross domestic products
but in constructing this chart he
ignored the advice of his Source the
Bureau of economic analysis or Bea in
two basic ways first the be tracks Bea
tracks not just wages and salaries but
the growing category that covers
benefits including pension and health
benefits benefits that are no doubt
important to Binya as a New York Times
employee second the Bea tracks not just
gross domestic product but net domestic
product net domestic product is simply
gross domestic product minus the
depreciation of capital and the Bea
instruction clearly conveys the point
that use of net domestic product is more
accurate in calculating this kind of
percentage I quote this from the Bea
handbook net domestic product is a
measure of how much of the nation's
output is available for consumption or
for adding to the nation's wealth
unquote
well here has been this chart
through the second quarter of this year
which takes wages and salaries as a
percentage of gross domestic products
now here is the same chart
with the corrections I take from the Bea
labor compensation which includes wages
salaries and benefits as a percentage of
net domestic product notice that benya's
downtrend disappears in this corrected
chart
properly measured it turns out to be a
relatively flat Trend and not as Spina
has written a smaller share of the pie
so I encourage him to go back to the
drawing board on all these issues thanks
[Applause]
thank you uh Gene Epstein
um we've got five minutes of rebuttal uh
do you want to you can use the handheld
mic either way you can sit or stand
we believe in Choice here
so there's a lot there thank you Gene
for your close engagement with my work I
appreciate it um
I didn't mention the uh data that Jane
spent most of his time talking about
because I don't think it's the most
important indicator of the problems in
the American economy it's an interesting
data point it's stylized you can take it
or leave it I think there has been a
downward Trend it is possible to cut the
data in ways that make it a little bit
bumpier a little smoother I concede that
point but I don't think it's the most
important Point as I said at the outset
by many measures the American economy
and aggregate has done quite well
where we are faltering is in the
distribution of prosperity not in the
creation of prosperity that is our
particular Challenge and that's why that
was not one of the points that I
actually made at the beginning of my
talk so you can take that for what it's
worth uh the more important thing is I
think Gene's absolutely right about
regulation I think it's one of these
issues where one needs to be nuanced
there are clearly areas and he quoted me
writing about one and I've written about
it repeatedly where I think that the
economy is over regulated in ways that
are enormously harmful and housing is
example number one
it is the case that we need more room
for the market to operate in the housing
sector it is the case that occupational
licensing is detrimental
and that our society has come to
tolerate unions for educated and highly
paid workers doctors real estate agents
where we don't allow them for low-paid
workers I think that's an enormous
problem
and one that we would all benefit from
from breaking down more of those walls
so this is a nuanced issue there's no
question about it I'm not here to tell
you that the free market is prevailed in
every respect I'm not here to tell you
that we wouldn't be better off by having
more of a market in some areas that
would be a Fool's errand and it would be
wrong and and those are clearly areas in
which the opposite is undoubtedly true I
do think that you know when Milton
Friedman was late in life and he was
asked you know to sort of reflect on his
achievement and he said oh gosh there's
so much left to do I just look at all
the arguments I haven't wanted I despair
that one uh you know would have been
remiss not to tell Friedman hey buddy
you want a lot more than you lost you've
succeeded in changing American society
in a lot of ways you've won massive
arguments about the role of monetary
policy about the role of Taxation about
the role of you know public spending
about the draft uh and and you should
rest on your laurels and and take
comfort and confidence in the fact that
UFC exceeded in many of those areas and
I always am a little bit puzzled when I
hear you know people uh bemoaning all
the ways in which they haven't made
progress fine well and good but but our
society has changed enormously
and and one shouldn't write that off
um it is true that the number of pages
in the Federal Register has increased
I'm not really sure what to take from
that fact it's a lot of any of you have
ever taken the time to read the Federal
Register it's a lot of extremely
complicated expositions one thing that
is definitely increased is the amount of
time that's required to justify each
regulation so pages and pages and pages
of the Federal Register are devoted to
elaborate proofs and research and public
surveys and all sorts of stuff how
exactly one correlates that with
regulatory intensity has never been
clear to me as I said before there are
clearly some areas in which we have too
much regulation and others in which we
have not enough
I don't think regulation is the central
area in which free market ideology has
prevailed to the detriment of our
society and and I hope that was clear
earlier
um one two specific things I guess that
I want to touch on uh in my remaining
time the first is auto accidents it's a
very famous example so you know early on
uh when you get out there and you've got
everybody driving in their new cars
at the rates of of Auto fatalities are
just astronomical there's a whole genre
of American music from that period
that's basically devoted to people dying
in auto accidents it was such a common
feature of life that
it infected our music for a time uh and
and it is true that in response to
Consumer demand car companies began to
introduce some safety features even
before Ralph Nader famously went before
Congress and called them out and forced
the government to begin regulating the
industry it is also true that the the
Auto industry was assiduously resisting
many of the features that are now
standard on American cars and have
contributed to a much sharper decline in
Auto fatalities since the Advent of
Federal Regulation than before it
and the reason for that is quite simply
that you need both things consumers
can't get there on their own they need
government to help them final Point
those Bea numbers that was a very final
illustration but the important point
there is benefits what those numbers
take into account is the growing share
of your compensation that comes in the
form of health care benefits it is not
clear to me that you are getting any
more value than you did a couple decades
ago from all of that increased spending
our life expectancies are in Decline we
are getting much less per dollar than
other countries but if you want to
include health care and take seriously
the proposition that it's several times
more valuable now than it was then then
by all means you can reverse that chart
thank you it's been young Gene
well quickly I I took benya's numbers
seriously uh because uh I believe that
they are his only attempt at some kind
of a rigorous analysis otherwise to make
a statement about how this bad thing has
happened and uh and look the the the
free market guys have been sounding off
more than they used to I think is
conjectural so I wanted to take his
analysis seriously and that's why I
quoted him emphasizing those numbers
both in an interview and in his book and
so I believe that it's a little bit
difficult for Binya to shrug that off
with respect to the federal the pages of
the Federal Register 58 000 pages to 180
000 Pages a tripling more than a
tripling from 1969. that should be
compelling enough evidence the burden of
Regulation is greater and of course
Vineyard didn't even question spending
by uh all levels of government
what else uh whether we with respect uh
to uh his uh his statement about
regulation of housing again I think he's
written some good stuff but the thing
that he does not seem to directly
confront is the very important research
that has shown that so many of the
things that he's talking about the
difficulty of the bottom half to get
decent jobs it's not just this idea that
that poor people would like to move into
the neighborhood and have decent housing
the mobility issue is is what has been
stressed by the peer reviewed research
that is very carefully said that that
the that the drain on these people's
incomes and the disparity in income the
resulting from housing regulation is
enormous so Binya is concerned as as we
all must be about about inequality that
in in my view is artificially caused by
government intervention then we're
talking about something Ultra important
and it makes it increasingly difficult
for him to argue that free market
knowledge ideologies largely to blame
for the things that bother him and
bother me when we're talking about
government that is largely to blame for
things like the fact that people have
difficulty finding new jobs when uh when
we start trading with China they the the
fact the fact that people have
difficulty functioning because they
can't get decent employment because of
the problems of housing that are so
severe and that Vineyard is at least
commendably beginning to tackle in his
columns in the New York Times so that's
why that's important with respect to
auto accidents again I I faulted Binya
for talking about the decline in poverty
not happening but I I would also have to
fall
with respect to auto accidents I don't
have the data in front of me but I
mentioned that in my initial talk the
fact is that accidents per passenger
mile met a proper measure of water
accidents we're declining steadily from
the 1920s on another factor to bear in
mind as well is that so much of the of
the intervention by government to make
cars supposedly better and more
expensive has meant that people of
limited means have difficulty affording
these cars difficult to 40 affording a
used car with with less than a hundred
thousand miles on so they buy the older
cars that could that are more dangerous
by virtue of being old so again he's
showing a certain indifference to the
law of unintended consequences but again
my point is that the auto accidents has
been a widely cited Point by those in
the free market the the order accident
rate was declined from the 1920s on and
and that kind of bias I believe is
something that Pena should overcome well
uh I guess oh yeah I guess I want to
show one other thing uh and uh and
that's the following I hope you can look
at this I've been here has talked about
fixing prices and about cartels let me
show this chart this is the PCA chain
price index the Federal Reserve follows
and the only thing I want you to be
aware of is that 12-month change in
price inflation from the 70s to the 80s
to the 90s into the Arts when when
supposedly all those price fixing
cartels were taking over has gotten more
and more mild until of course 1920 2020
when when other things began to happen
having to do with the printing of money
to take a look at airline fares there
too the airlines were supposedly
carteling this supposedly organizing
against us and yet if you look at this
chart the prices of airline fares based
upon the CPR we're going negative
through the odds so again I would want
him to show me some evidence in the
official prices that cartilization is
such a problem thanks
thank you Gene okay we're now at the uh
question and answer period so if you
have a question would you please line up
in front of the microphone you can
identify yourself or not but you must
ask a question not give a speech and
while people are queuing up uh there's
only two there and I would expect that
most of the audience would be rushing
over there
um can I I just want to ask I'll take
the moderator's prerogative to ask each
of you a question Gene uh kind of
philosophically
is it possible for you to admit that
market forces an increase in Market
Freedom or Market forces could leads
lead to worse outcomes do you believe in
market failure or regardless of whatever
evidence that Binya Marshalls or not
you'd be like it can't be the free
market because the free market never
does anything wrong markets fail us all
the time
markets faces father faces all of the
time in in the economic Realm government
in the economic realm faces uh fails us
more often and so for that reason uh I
would want to say that again the
approach that Binya is taking is he sees
a problem and the problem may exist and
it may be due to markets that I I can't
think of a good example of hand but it
may be due to markets the question is
for example do we have auto accidents
our cause is well made as they might be
well is government doing us more harm
than good more good than harm we don't
know for sure we have to look at it a
little bit more carefully than
progressives look at it but again I want
to emphasize again markets fail us all
the time it's a non-secretory to say
that government is the solution okay
thank you uh Benya can I ask you uh
quickly
does this your your argument is based
that we've you know we've had dismal
economic performance relative to the
past or relative to what might be
because of an increase in free market
ideology throughout Society does the
fact that the United States has lost
ground in the in the 21st century pretty
continuously in every index of economic
freedom or of global business
competitiveness does that temper your
argument at all or do you or not
so I think that you know those indices
are are interesting creatures they're
they tend to be produced by advocacy
groups but I think that there is no
doubt as I've said several times tonight
that there are areas in which the United
States does restrict markets to the
detriment of our economy and our society
and then I think there are areas in
which we are are overconfident in the
value of markets so it is a complex
picture and there are undoubtedly areas
in which you know we're doing the wrong
thing by not relying enough on markets
uh I I don't think that I'm compelled by
the evidence that we are in some
aggregate sense you know moving away
from a Reliance on markets I don't see
that happening in a meaningful sense so
if that's the question
um I'd want to see more evidence for
that proposition okay let's go to the
audience sir please ask a question yeah
my question is forbina in that program
that you mentioned where they were
looking for cartels do you know how many
were identified and how many were
regulated or how how they were regulated
I don't have the numbers here off the
top of my head but uh the regulation was
that I mean if a cartel is is illegal so
if they have evidence of a cartel they
take a criminal enforcement action
against it and there were some famous
cases in that period probably the most
famous is the ADM price fixing cartel
that became a big Hollywood movie in
which they were fixing the the price of
several basic you know components in in
you know several uh additives that went
into a wide variety of uh you know food
products in collaboration with firms in
in Asia the other major producers were
in Japan and South Korea I think and
there was this whole famous FBI sting on
it but there were a whole series I mean
what was remarkable about it was you
know that the program was overwhelmed by
these one of my favorite stories about
it is you know one of the lawyers who's
involved in this took a client down to
Dallas to be the first ones to get in
the door at the doj office there and as
they were walking into the parking lot
they ran into one of their rival firms
one of the fellow participants in the
cartel walking out of the office
I won't repeat what was said
um at that time
I just want to comment briefly and again
just repeat that look if you want to
find evidence for cartels and Benya
mentioned prices fixing prices you
should see it in the official price
indexes a Pina has in another interview
mentioned Airline cartilization let's
talk about Airlines yeah
and again if you look at the Consumer
Price Index it's the official uh price
index and it has a Sub sub component
called airfares and I showed the the
chart where airfares were dropping most
years from 2000 to the present until of
course 2021 when I believe Benya
understands that new things happening
but we we have had an increasing of
price dampening uh in in Airlines and in
all markets and yet we're supposed to
believe that there's a lot of cartels
price fixing please find some evidence
in the prices that are officially quoted
and then I might be be able to lend some
germ of truth to this argument because
there is evidence for it and the
evidence is the comparison between the
United States and Europe what we have
seen over the last three decades is that
the European airfare Market which is
much more competitive than the United
States much less concentrated where
Airlines have not been able to acquire
their competitor airfares per air mile
are much lower in Europe as a
consequence than they are in the United
States well
well don't go back to the slides a very
quick point I want to make a brief
comment there are structural factors
that are causing a general decline in
airfare those are undoubtedly true and
you can see them exerting their
influence on American airfares but if
you compare our performance with theirs
they're doing better I showed a slide I
showed a slide I only want to mention to
bring you that that a better test would
be the us against its own history and
the slide I showed was that airfares
were from the 80s to the night to the
70s to the 80s the 90s every decade
thereafter successive decade airfare
inflation dropped so a better comparison
would be the U.S market against itself
and in most years in the arts for
airfare prices we're going to ask that
we move on to the next question I think
you both have aired this uh very well so
thank you sir question
question for Mr Applebaum so
I think I'm sorry did you say it's
roundabout no Mr applebound okay thank
you because I was going to say if it's a
roundabout hit the road it's gonna be
very direct
um I think most people would say that
two of the biggest reasons for the poor
performance of the U.S economy in recent
decades are the last two big recessions
the one since you know covid and also
the 2008 recession
so your colleague at the New York Times
Paul Kirkman recently admitted that the
stimulus bill that was passed in early
2021 did not stimulate the economy as
they predicted on the basis of Keynesian
economic theory and the data shows the
very same thing with respect to the
Obama stimulus bill in 2009 to get us
out of the 08 financial crisis and
recession
and this and the reasons behind that and
the prediction that these stimulus bills
would fail was made by free market
economists way ahead of time and for
decades before that
so the question to you is why do you
ignore these two data points which are
totally antithetical to your thesis
okay thank you
so first of all as I think I mentioned
my view is that the 2008 recession was
caused by the deregulation of the
financial industry it's a classic
example of the government getting out of
the way and allowing people to wreck
their cars as it were and so you know my
view is that the subprime mortgage
industry was basically a grand
experiment in holding a party on the
roof of a very tall building and every
time someone walked off the edge
pronouncing that it was their fault and
never getting around to asking whether
at some point you should build a fence
around the roof so that people cannot
walk off the edge anymore and what we
had was a financial system premised on
the ability of people to make good
choices about complicated financial
instruments that they didn't understand
and then we got a crash as a consequence
whether the government's response to
that crash was or wasn't effective I'm
not sure of the basis for your assertion
and I have my own but to me the more
important Point here is that we got into
trouble because of our Reliance on free
market ideology
Gene do you have a well the soil form
did have a debate on this issue a while
back uh
just to again Parry Pena we have a deep
disagreement about this
strict suggestion start reading the
public statements of Bill Clinton who
who
urged that we get the home ownership
rate up from uh from the mid 60 percent
range to 70 percent read the statements
of George W bush about how we have
inequality of Housing and the government
needs to Goose up housing look at the
fact that into the year 2000 most of the
toxic mortgages were owned by a
government-sponsored Enterprises called
Fanny and Freddie and look at the price
Rises that were occurring then 12 13 up
and then and then the crony capitalists
came in only then did they come in but
what set the stage for the housing
bubble uh was the the early 90s into the
Arts with Clinton Bush and Barney Frank
being the major cheerleaders for this
and by the way also including Alan
Greenspan
and the invention of the saw and the
nail and the house I mean you can go
back in history as far as you want the
housing market didn't crash in 2000 it
crashed after the subprime industry
started mass producing loans that people
couldn't afford to repay and Wall Street
started packaging them into derivatives
that didn't produce the expected
revenues that's the story of the housing
crash the Prelude isn't irrelevant but
it's also not the core of the story well
just a brief response Fannie and Freddie
went broke they had huge losses and
Fannie and Freddie were
government-sponsored Enterprises they
set the stage the private sector came in
later lunatics by the way who were not
the mortgage broker who would not give
you the mortgage they were they were a
preacher of the federal government as
well we have a deep disability stand
there yeah well said uh question sir yes
thank you for the debate it was very uh
enticing my name is Brendan and my
question is more at a philosophical
level which is that
um I think just stepping back this is
we've kind of been down this road before
where there's been a lot of populism of
the left and the right a lot of
anti-immigrant sentiment
um and just general
negativity around the US
yeah just like how
um just like the populism that's growing
in this country it's this isn't the
first time we've been here if you look
at the 70s if you look at World War II
we even had a civil war and my question
is
what is your outlook on the future are
we we kind of been through this before
we always get through it are we going to
get through this one and you know is it
kind of just going to work itself out
um what's your thoughts on that okay is
that um please take opinion
Gene quoted me earlier saying that I
don't know much about the past I know
even less about the future so I'm not
trying to answer that question
well uh uh my my future is that first of
all I want Binya just my narrow Focus
tonight is I want Benya to write more
articles about housing for the New York
Times they're very good and I want to
send them the citations and the research
on why it's so fundamental in causing
the very thing that concerns them so
much uh widening inequality and and
short life spans of the of you of the
Americans so that's what I want for the
future and I think Ben is headed in the
right direction he's had a few pieces
there's a member of the audience who
came up to me at the beginning of the
program tonight to say that she wished
that we achieved consensus in tonight's
discussion Gene I mean listen on housing
I am a hundred percent with you well
we've done it well I can yeah I think
you want to put more of a cutting edge
all right let's uh let's go to a new
question don't don't spoil the moment
don't spoil the moment sir a question
please thank you both for great debate
today so my first question comes after
you only get one so pick one okay so any
one questions so my question comes to
the Past tubing yeah since like Jin
provided two key data to Define if the
U.S economy has become more and more
regulated in past decades do you agree
with him if not how how do you define if
an economy is more regulated or free and
besides the comparison between us and
Europe thank you thank you I appreciate
that we're regulating the number of
questions
um I would say that I think that it is
very difficult and there have been very
very sophisticated efforts to do this
but to Define regulatory intensity the
way you definitely don't want to do it
is by counting pages in the Federal
Register which is I'm not sure what it's
a metric of but there are clearly areas
in which I think any reasonable Observer
would conclude that the economy is less
regulated than it used to be the airline
industry is a great example the federal
government used to regulate prices the
number of seats where you could fly what
kinds of sandwiches you could serve
there was a federal agency that did all
of these things that agency no longer
exists the government no longer
regulates those things the airline
industry has a lot more freedom than it
used to financial markets another
example where there has been a clear
Trend toward deregulation we've seen uh
you know in in that area and you know
conversely there are areas in which the
market like housing has become much more
regulated so how you aggregate all that
across an economy how you figure out
what regulatory density is it's a really
complicated theoretical issue I don't
think there are good answers I will just
repeat what I said at the outset which
is that I don't think the intensity of
Regulation is the key respect in which
free market ideology has has exercised
its influence over the American economy
I have a question for you been here
picking up on that I thought you were
basically uh thought that the abolition
of the the cab and the Civil aeronautics
that regulation was a good thing yeah so
I think it had positive effects and and
if it had been coupled with antitrust
enforcement it might have been an
entirely happy story okay yeah okay
uh sir question uh for Mr Applebaum you
mentioned uh life expectancy flattening
or declining and carbon emissions
growing uh but my understanding is the
life expectancy declining is largely
driven by obesity and drugs kind of
Cheaper food and cheaper drugs available
in carbon emissions by more energy
consumption and so is this not uh dismal
but rather we're kind of trading bad
problems for better problems
yeah I mean the sort of the agony of
excess is kind of an American phenomenon
right but so I think that you know the
best research on this has been done by
encase and Angus Deaton and and they
talk about what they call uh you know
the deaths of Despair this sense that
we're seeing increased uh younger
mortality among you know in particular
lower income Americans who have lost
hope lost the ability to function in the
economy lost the ability to find
meaningful employment and that they have
turned to drugs and done Healthy
Lifestyles and in many cases even
suicide as a consequence uh so you know
that that's it there is absolutely the
opportunity to you know do these things
because we live in a society of
abundance the question is do people have
what is the nature of our relationship
with that abundance there's a healthy
way to live in that context in an
unhealthy way and you know the decline
in life expectancy reflects people
making choices that they didn't used to
make and the question is why well just
very quickly I'll just point out the
two-thirds of deaths of Despair are men
deal with that but Gene you were yeah I
I also want to point out Gene is now
75 77.
you are the opposite of a death of
despair
78 next month 78 even more so incredible
um again
I hope Benya when he answers that
question the future will ask himself
again where where's the immobility of
Labor he spoke very articulately about
the restrictive licensure all of those
things that cause labor to be immobile
that make it hopeless for you to seek a
better better employment in highways
areas I wish he'd focus on that a little
bit more than he already has so I when
he talks about those depths of Despair
connected to government policies all
right um we have a an online question uh
which is Fort Binya it says aside from
free market capitalism what other
societal construct has been more fair
and Equitable to its citizenry
so I mean I I think that free market
capitalism is uh it depends what you
mean by that I think that there's a
version of capitalism that is optimal
for our society I'm not here to advocate
for something other than capitalism I
believe that capitalism works best when
it is embedded in the context of of a
strong government and a clear sense of
of Civic purpose I think that when we
provide a social safety net when we
provide people with the opportunity to
prosper and ensure that they have access
to what I think of as the infrastructure
of opportunity the stuff that New
Yorkers take for granted public transit
high quality schools uh you know
recreational opportunities uh you know
that this is uh a context in which
people can flourish and to take
advantage of the free market and when
you have a free market that is not
embedded in those things the results are
worse it is not the question for me is
not whether or not we want capitalism
there is no viable alternative to
capitalism uh the question is how do we
maximize the benefits of cap realism how
do we ensure that we collectively are
prospering and that is what I want to
see
okay just ask before Gene uh is is there
could you let me answer the question I'm
the moderator I'm sorry you chose I know
I know you're the moderator
if I may though is there a stopping
point for you
sorry with free markets that's the
default setting what is the stopping
point where you say okay you know what
um we either have to start regulating or
regulation becomes too onerous you know
we live on the slopes I think one of the
worst things that uh Hayek ever wrote
was that you know that it's a slippery
slope and once you begin regulating who
knows where it's going to go we live on
that slope there are no absolutes in
this game uh and and so you're
constantly engaged in calibration you're
constantly asking how do we balance the
benefits of the market and the downsides
how do we you know find the right role
for government to play and there is no
answer and even if you arrive at the
right answer in a given moment you will
need to adjust it in time okay that is
the work of government thank you Nick
look
the other dimension to this that I wish
Benya a lot younger than I uh and many
years of of productive writing and
thinking ahead of him would contemplate
is crony capitalism uh he quoted George
stickler but he hasn't quoted George
Stigler on his concept of regulatory
capture that that obviously if you give
the government a lot of power if the
government has a lot of money to throw
around if it can clamp down on different
businesses then business that is well
placed is going to get the picture and
is going to start uh conspiring with
government and we see it everywhere we
saw it with Pfizer and the vaccines
recently uh we we we see it in the
financial industry we we see the
revolving door between those who run
Goldman Sachs and those who run the
government and so the the the the
utopian picture that Benya paints is
something I wish he would abandon and
understand that when you give government
an enormous amount of power business
that is well placed is going to get the
pick picture and you will have what I
have colloquel really called capitalism
a contraction of crony capitalism the
Unholy alliance between big government
and big business that causes cartels to
the extent that we have them
would you like to
I mean I have to say briefly I think one
needs to always be looking at what is
the alternative and and if the
alternative it is no question that
Goldman Sachs has a malign influence
over the federal government apologies to
any Goldman Sachs employees who are
present this evening but the question is
you know if there wasn't a federal
government and Goldman Sachs could just
do whatever the hell it wanted would
that be a better situation and to my
mind the answer is clearly no we we need
constantly to be engaged in the work of
improving the quality of this balance
but it doesn't mean you can't just throw
yes crony capitalism exists and and so
therefore what what do we do as a
consequence I'm gonna put that question
to you what what is your preferred
alternative well well as a embroidered
breaststrokes in the profit and loss
system profits encourage risk-taking
losses encourage Prudence when you bring
the government in to provide a safety
net below below the where the banks can
go or where General Motors can go or
Christ wouldn't go when you abolish
losses in the capitalist system then you
have problems but if Government backs
off let them lose let them go bankrupt
if they make wrong decisions and that
will tend to get them to behave better
because capitalism can sometimes be
pretty cruel to those capitalists in
charge if they make wrong decisions by
imposing on them losses in the in the
prophet and profit and loss system known
as capitalism
I mean I just think that when Goldman
Sachs is allowed to run free we've seen
that it does indeed behave cruelly and
it does indeed impose massive losses I'm
not sure that Society ends up better off
as a consequence all right I think thank
you for that exchange thank you for your
questions thank you for your online
question as well out there in the dark
uh Gene you have five minutes
of a closing stick
I apologize for uh disrupting the flow
uh Benya you have five minutes to uh to
bring it on home
so I mean I think this has been an
Illuminating exchange this evening and
I'm grateful to Gene for asking me to
participate in it and what I really want
to emphasize in closing which may not be
the best strategy for a debater but uh
it's closest to where I think the truth
lies is that we are dealing with uh a
calibration issue it is not the case
that we are going to live in a world in
which markets get to decide everything
or in which government gets to decide
everything those are not the choices
that we're confronted by and often when
I hear these types of questions debated
I hear a reflective tendency to frame
things in those terms and to assert that
you know government is the problem or
that markets are the problem and the
reality in my view is that the problem
is an improper or incomplete or
imperfect synthesis of governments and
markets Carl Palani who was a wonderful
writer in the mid-century and lived
through a lot of bad things and Drew
some pretty bleak conclusions from The
Experience wrote that there's a constant
negative tension between society and the
market that they exist in a state of
trying to debilitate each other
the market constantly preying on society
Society constantly preying on the market
and I think that that Bleak Vision
actually gets things wrong I think that
what America has been for most of its
history is a society in which society in
the market are engaged in a constructive
if immensely frustrating relationship
constantly building on each other
constantly trying to take advantage of
each other but to climb up on top and
then up and up and so through our
history we have seen the market produce
prosperity and we have seen Society make
choices about how to manage and
distribute that Prosperity often in ways
that ended up producing more
market-driven prosperity and then more
distribution of the gains more
prosperity in a virtuous cycle that is
the reality that I think we need to
continue to perfect that is the world in
which I would like to live is a world in
which the government has its role and so
do the markets and there are clear
really going to be areas like housing in
which the solution at a given time is
for the market to play a much larger
role and there are areas I think
healthcare comes to mind for me in which
I think the government could
productively engage with Market forces
and produce better outcomes than we get
right now
and even if you disagree about those
particulars even if you think that
Health Care is the opposite or housing
is the opposite which is a surprisingly
popular Viewpoint in New York you still
are going to be talking about the
calibration and you're still going to be
ultimately debating not whether we
should have markets or whether we should
have government but how we get the best
possible relationship between markets
and government Milton Friedman famously
observed that government
is best off if it can reserve to the
market as much decision making as
possible and that then it can restrict
the work that the citizens have to do
and that'll make things easier if you
can limit the number of decisions we
need to arrive at collectively uh you'll
limit the burden of making those
decisions and I've always thought that
he got things fundamentally wrong that
in that respect what you really want to
be doing as a society is exercising your
collective decision making capacity
because it's a muscle and it needs to be
used in order to grow stronger and in
order to produce better results
and so I think that you know for me when
we talk about these questions about you
know uh how we get the best results in
Auto Safety or how we get the best
results in the airline sector or in
housing for that matter her you know the
very fact that we're here having a
discussion tonight the very fact that
these are discussions that people have
all the time reflect the tendency not
just to rely on Market forces but to
want to manage them and to want to think
about the role that they play in our
society and to want to make rules that
allow them to play uh that role as
productively as possible I'm just going
to go back to the beginning uh in
closing because jeans harped on it
several times tonight I gave you three
specific metrics at the beginning three
data points by which I think our society
has deteriorated in recent decades I
told you that the distribution of growth
means that for most Americans the
economic Prosperity has not lifted their
ships as much as it has in other
countries I told you that average life
expectancy has been in Decline and
particularly for those who are the least
well off in our society and I told you
that the chances that you will do better
than your parents have sharply declined
as economic mobility in our society has
declined those three problems in my view
are all rooted in the failures of our
ideology of our governing ideology in a
tendency to rely too much on Market
forces in to make that balance imperfect
it's my belief that if we corrected that
balance not to get rid of the market but
to introduce government as a stabilizing
force that we would get better results
and with any luck I've convinced some of
you of that this evening thank you
thank you very much Pena Applebaum Gene
well uh you know we we might uh I think
in terms of the the history that I've
lived through since I was born in 1944
is that uh back back in the 1960s uh uh
John Kenneth Galbraith who uh uh not an
economist I respect but I certainly read
and was talking about the dominance of
the cartels like General Motors and then
cut to decades later and uh General
Motors is a basket case and uh Barack
Obama bails out General Motors we we've
recently had a moment when a drug
company Pfizer brings out a vaccine and
and the government protects Pfizer
against any liability and uh and so
again I would only emphasize that that
that the lure of power The Lure of money
is such that inevitably if you're going
to get government more involved you're
going to get business more involved
you're going to get not more free market
capitalism not more of anything what
that Pena honestly wants you're going to
get more capitalism more crony
capitalism and that's the danger the
housing market is indeed a crony
capitalist Market because the
established developers in the Inner
Circle like it because they have friends
in government they can build and they
don't have to suffer competition and so
that too is something that Binya should
argue against when he mistakes nicely of
the developers which I think is good he
should understand that some developers
actually continue to want scarcity in
housing some landlords want scarcity in
housing obviously it keeps the rents up
so that too is the crony capitalist
system that I wish Benya would do more
to object to but broadly speaking I I
want to certainly give Binya the Tootsie
Roll for character development this
evening because I believe that he's
given sufficient ground to to to
basically concede my point he has
graciously graciously borne the burden
of of arguing that the free market is
largely responsible and yet he's given
ground on so many points that that he
seems to be arguing both the earlier to
earlier after after we spoke and and now
most recently in a summation that it's a
mixed bag and I don't have enough time
we've raised so many issues about what's
gone on in the last 50 to 60 years as I
say it's a vast topic I believe the
Federal Reserve should be abolished I
think the Federal Reserve is part of the
problem it's not a free market the
Federal Reserve is not a free market
institution it's it's Soviet style
planning for the money supply and the
interest rate and and it's caused the
inflation that we're suffering at least
it's been part and parcel of having
caused it initially of course it was the
huge pileup of debt in in starting in
March 2020 which the Federal Reserve
then underwrote by printing money and
then that money printing went into the
economy and now we're looking at eight
percent price inflation but the Federal
Reserve didn't exist it wouldn't be
there to underwrite all of these things
so that's a very long story and I
haven't had the nearly enough time to
touch on any any aspect but the surface
of it but all I want to say really is
that Benya has raised some points I've
raised some points but he's basically
failed to Bear the burden of showing
that for the free market Bears law is
largely responsible when he's already
manfully and graciously conceded so much
in our debate this evening thank you
very much
[Applause]
all right thank you uh Gene and thank
you Benya that was a great debate I
think uh everybody learned a lot
um and now comes the final vote
if you in order for your votes count you
need to uh double up so you got to vote
again and while we are calculating the
debate uh the votes uh the information
on where to vote is up on the screens I
will tell you about the coming uh
will be selling books for 10 bucks
ten dollars and you know by tomorrow
they're probably going to be 11 or 12
dollars so you want to you want to get
it now okay build a house out of them
at the after party at jeans uh and if
you have questions about where the after
party uh takes place talk to us right
after the debate
um but uh what we have coming up and I
guess actually even before I get that I
want to give a shout out to Gene not to
influence your voting but for founding
co-founding and directing the Soho Forum
we have these kinds of civil debates on
really important interesting topics on a
monthly basis in a city that is famous
for giving people you know the Bronx
cheer is the least awful of the cheers
that the different boroughs give people
when they get mad at them so thank you
Gene for heading up the uh so before
other so upcoming Soho Forum events
include on Tuesday November 15th
Stanford University professor of
medicine Jay bhattacharya will defend
the resolution the pandemic Treaty of
the World Health Organization should
focus on targeted protection of
high-risk groups consistent with the
approach taken by the Great Barrington
declaration and he'll be uh going up
against Yale professor of Public Health
stend vermand
on Wednesday December 14th National
Review editor-in-chief Rich Lowry will
defend the resolution nationalism is an
important value that Americans should
support against Cato Institute senior
fellow Alex narasta
on Thursday January 26th uh University
Mission George Mason University
professor of Economics Lawrence white
will defend the resolution
replacing the Federal Reserve with free
market institutions would significantly
improve the money the economy's money
Banking and Financial systems and he's
going to be going up against Columbia
University professor of banking excuse
me and financial institutions Lawrence
Michigan on February 21st Tuesday if
you're counting mises Institute senior
fellow Ryan mcmaken will defend the
resolution the breakup of the United
States into distinct regions is a
workable option likely to bring a market
Improvement in human Affairs and he's
going to be going up against libertarian
party classical liberal caucus chair
Jonathan Casey in March 23rd on Thursday
March 23rd Ein Rand Institute executive
director yaron Brook will defend the
resolution of narco-capitalism would
definitely be a complete disaster for
Humanity and he'll be uh taking on
George Mason University economics
professor Brian Kaplan that should be be
a first fate Monday April 24th Cato
Institute senior fellow Alex narasto
will come back
and he will defend the resolution U.S
immigration policy should be U.S
immigration policy B should should
excuse me U.S immigration policy should
be to issue immigration visas without
numerical limitations to all applicants
who are not on a terrorist watch list
and who do not otherwise have criminal
records contagious diseases or cell
phones that go off in the middle of
people reading upcoming events at the
solo forum and he's going to be taking
on Manhattan contrarian blogger Francis
Menton those are fantastic debates
coming up how are we doing on the vote
anyone is anybody Counting
okay you need a little bit more time
I am
very excited to see okay so now uh as we
recall and I will probably screw this up
because I am a multiple English major up
through the PHD level so you know I
Outsource my math to people like Gene
but this is an Oxford style debate so
the winner is the person who gets more
people to agree with them over the
course of the debate so in the before
the debate the uh yes votes the people
who were agreeing with Binya correct
that was 7.37 percent of you and we are
going to take it I'm surprised we're not
taking it to a third decimal place
given what that means
um so the the people starting out who
agreed with Pena was 7.3 percent Gene
the agreement with Gene was
68.42 percent
so Binya went from 7.37 to afterwards
16.84 so the change was 9.47
uh and I guess I should also uh tell you
uh just to keep these suspense going a
little bit longer the undecided people
were 24.21 before the debate
uh but so the no people the people who
are on Gene's side went from 68.42 to
74.74 for a gain of 6.32 which means
that Binya Applebaum came into the
Tiger's den and bearded the lion just to
mix many metaphors Kenya is the winner
thank you
and
and he gets the Tootsie Roll which by
the way is one of I think one uh item
that has defied inflation I think it
might be as cheap as it was when these
first started pulling fillings out of uh
people
thank you so much for coming out
um
go to the reception buy a book talk with
Gene enjoy hasaka's fantastic Buffet
it's truly a world of Wonders thank you
all for coming and we'll see you on
Tuesday November 15th when Jay
bhattacharya and Sten Vermont discuss
things